شعور اغير ويعني ما كنتش مفكر انه حيصير
هيك ولا حيكون حيصير هيك وهيكون في حرب ما
كنتش عارف كنت مكيف و كنت عيش بالحياه
غيرت من حياتي كثير هذ هذه الحرب صبين عني
بدي اشتغل واشيل يعني بلاط من الشارع بروح
اخر الدنيا بس عشان اجيب حبه وقيده
[موسيقى]
وبلاط كانوا عايشين ومبسوطين كل وقتهم
للعب
ودراسه انا اضطريت اخلي ادي يجمعوا الحطب
علشان نطبخ نسخن نعمل شاي مثلا احنا ما
بنطبخ كثير لانه برضه تعب ومش دائما
بتلاقيه متوفر الحطب لحاله ابني صار يروح
انا ما طلبت منه رحت انا بس ابني لما
شافني قاللي لا انت ما تروحيش يا ماما انا
اللي بدي
اروح الككاو الشا الككاو انا اسمي فراس
سكافي من سكان شجعيه غزه عمري ثمان سنين
صف ثالث انا فتحت البسطه بس عشان اساعد
اهلي واجيب اكل كل يوم منها يا ابوي ويا
امي ويا اخواتي ويا
اهلي اسمي
اتير صف سادس عمري 12 و كنت من ولد شاطر
بالمدرسه تحولت الى كنت صرت اشتغل و ش
الوقيد انقلبت الحياه بس كنت اروح بالحطب
كنت فخور بنفسي يعني عشان اجيب حطبه نولع
عليها يعني اهلي نعمل كاسه شاي او قهوه او
[موسيقى]
شيء انا الطالبه لانا خالد عويضه عمري 10
سنين من خانيونس احنا تهجرنا لرفح و كت
نفسي ارجع للمدرسه لاني كنت شاطره كثير
كنت اتعب واجتهد عشان اجيب علامه حلوه انا
غسلت عشان ماما تعبت واخويا محمد
اواعي وما عندهوش ملابس
كفايه هي هنا ه اولادنا مفروض اللي زيهم
بس يكون متفرغ للعب وللدراسة
[موسيقى]
الان له ثلاث شهور تقريبا حوالي شهرين ونص
ما بدرس طيب طبيعي بده ينسى كل العلم انا
جبت الكتب وحاولت ادرسه الولد مش قادر
يستوعب من كثر الضرب والقصف عقلهم في
الحرب متى بدها توقف الحرب متى يا ماما
صاروا يسالوني اسئله في السياسه وفي الحرب
بطلوا يدوروا على العلم من الخوف طيب ايش
بده يعمل الواحد بده يطلع جيل
فاشل انا نفسي اروح على المدرسه عشان اص
شاطر واصير
منيح وابطل ا
شاقه كثير بشتاق للحياه العاديه كنت بس
اروح على المدرسه وانقلبت الحياه الحرب
على الاطفال صعبه جدا عشان الاطفال
بيقدروش يتحملوا اما الرجال اه بيقدروا
يتحمله